hello everybody and welcome to the
second part of our matplotlib a mini
series in Python 3 in the last video we
showed how to do a very basic plot of X
and y we hard-coded the values in there
and in this video I'd like to show you
guys that you don't have to do that how
do you get around that and then also
will show some labels and then also an
error that you might see it and not
understand what that means
so with that it's going to get started
so PLT dot plot generally in your
scripts you're going to be plotting very
like values that you're signed of
variables that you're getting from some
sort of source so you might have you
know source online a database a CSV file
something like that and then you're
going to be pulling those and then
putting them as a list into a variable
so you're going to have a x and a y and
then x and y will equal something in our
case we're just going to say they equal
a list and now what we can do is just
copy and paste these values basically
into our lists
so that was our X and our Y and then
here you just plot X Y and that's really
all there is to it there so then we can
save and run that and we get you know
our graph that we saw before so you know
nothing's really changed so now what we
can do though is if you paid attention
in school you know that you have to
include titles and labels to everything
ok so this is a bad chart so how do we
add titles and labels we have PLT title
and this will add a title to the chart
we'll just call it epic chart and then
we have P LTI label and then this we can
just I don't know Y axis and then PLT
dot X label and we'll call this x axis
so save it on that and now we can see
we've given our chart a nice title why
label and an axel Abel okay close that
this now finally the last thing I just
want to show you guys is the X&Y here uh
we're assuming that we've have we have
some sort of function that's or a class
or something that's come through and
populated these values again we've card
coded it here but normally you probably
wouldn't you'd have some something
assigning values to these variables so
sometimes the following happens and you
get this error value error X&Y must have
the same first dimension now the first
time I saw this error I had no idea what
the heck that meant X and Manos have the
same four Weitzel a what does that even
mean no and so maybe like the first
dimension is lengths I don't have no
idea but anyway you have that anytime
you're plotting obviously we've got more
X's than we have Y's so it goes to plot
X and then it has no y to match and so
we get in a little bit of trouble here
so um so whenever you see that hair just
know that that's what's happening so
usually what the next thing I'll do
whenever something like that happens is
either I look at the code and spot what
what has happened or you can always
print Len X and then basically copy
paste print Len Y and then you could
even do this right let's add back our
zero
save and run that and before we get to
this error that says that we can see up
here well we've got a five and a four we
printed X first and we can see here that
L yeah X has five values Y on the s4 so
now we need to consult our code and
figure out what we've done wrong so
anyway that's pretty common error at
least that I see a lot in my own code so
anyway so that's that that's a little
error how to add labels and then also
plot plot variables which not not too
not too confusing so the next thing that
I wanted to cover is save and run this
one time you know this chart
I mean his epic chart as it is
it's pretty boring looking chart and so
there's a couple of things that we can
do one we can go through we can
customize everything ourselves or we can
in the code rather you customize
everything or we can use what are called
styles which is kind of a new addition
to matplotlib and we can use these
styles to kind of store specific formats
to charts that we want so anyway that's
what we're going to be covering in the
next video is styles and so that will
help you make very quick decent looking
charts and then you can further
customize later on if you want but
anyway that's what we'll be talking
about in the next video of styles if you
guys have any questions or comments on
this video feel free to leave them below
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time